now you're all familiar uh with the uh
broadway musical spider-man and haven't
it's yeah
it's been having its troubles and uh
what had to close down for a while well
now they're about to reopen the
spider-man musical yeah the producers
have totally retooled it
and they've added all new villains
and i think it's a much better show i
checked it out and i'm excited to say
that the producers of the broadway
musical have given me the exclusive
right to show the new villains here
tonight on the
show that would that be cool
now first up
peter grey
totally improves the musical first up
spider-man's arch enemy doc ock has been
replaced by a villain who reflects
america's fun and casual lifestyle
please welcome doc crock
[Applause]
[Music]
our next villain wants to destroy
spider-man almost as much as he wants to
save the planet it's the environmentally
green goblin
[Applause]
reduce
reuse
recycle
[Applause]
think globally
act locally
buy organic
that that took too long this next
spider-man villain
is terrifying especially for interior
decorators please welcome beanbagio the
cartwheeling beanbag
[Applause]
i go with nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
this next villain's a famous evil jedi
who's got a good reason to be angry his
clothes are still at the cleaners it's
laundry day darth vader
[Applause]
our next bad guy is a master of stealth
with just one weakness his failure to
break in his brand new shoes please
welcome new shoes ninja
[Applause]
[Music]
i didn't say they were all good all
right
hey but we saved the scariest villain
for last please give a hand to leprechon
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the new spider-man
villains give it up for him right there